justin here with a gamespot news update
pizza and video games have always been a
great combination but best buy is taking
that combo to a whole new level if you
preorder the wii u rpgs you know Blake
Chronicles X you'll get ten dollars and
eat pizza cash which you can use to buy
pizza the only thing we're spending
money on besides video games there are
some limitations however first you must
place order by December third 2015 the
game launches on December fourth and
complete your purchase by December 10th
in addition the collector's edition is
excluded from this promotion and orders
are limited to one per person do that
and you'll receive a code for ten
dollars and eat pizza cash that you can
then enter at XCX pizza cash calm to get
a voucher good anywhere in the united
states where mastercard is accepted you
need to redeem the code by january
fourteenth 2016 to give the pizza
voucher which you must then use before
january thirty first if you want more
details on this somewhat complicated
deal head over to bestbuy com and find
the pizza cache page if you're a pizza
hater it doesn't technically sound like
you have to spend the cash on pizza
however Xenoblade Chronicles X is a
spiritual successor to monolith soft we
are PG Xenoblade Chronicles earlier in
2015 nintendo released a 3ds port of
xenoblade chronicles which gamespot
editor john robertson scored an eight
how much pizza can you get for ten
dollars not a lot and what does pete to
have to do with xenoblade chronicles
Aleph I know but for even more on pizza
and video games stay to the game spot